this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer from Disney and the same director
as the rick roll video weird comes a
film released one year after Nic Cage
took on the rock and just three weeks
before he take off a phase I'd like to
take his his face oh wow it's a miracle
any of us survived peak Nic Cage
especially Nick Cage con air all aboard
con air and airplane for the worst
criminals some unarmed guards one
undercover agent and an American hero
with a terrible lawyer admit to it you
shall remain incarcerated for a term not
less than seven to ten years when this
plane takes off so does the action
culminating in amazing set pieces some
outlandish comedy and the world's most
high-stakes unboxing video back in the
box yeah it's easy but it has as many
Oscar nominations its verdict oh so you
tell me which one's better Nic Cage is
Poe Dameron III mean Poe Cameron I mean
Cameron Poe he's a former Army Ranger
with a past manslaughter in the first
degree and even that past has a past for
a second there you were there
I was hoping maybe the army would make
that guy
and not even that past past can explain
his accent let make sure that is better
ground I am however torn apart when I
think that I won't be there to see our
child coming to the world started this
day with birthday party to get to and
I'm gonna get to it
he's got a be like the love child of
Mufasa and Fabio a daughter he won't
shut up about you wanna see my daddy for
the first time demo yep it's my
daughter's birthday we get it it's my
daughter's birthday today you gotta go
back my daughter's picture put my
picture chick I'm afraid my daughter
won't in the studio etc this is my
daughter I didn't know you had a
daughter and his sheer awesomeness will
conjure sweet ass guitar legs out of
thin air
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna show you God doesn't exist I
want it to be all when I walk into a
room someday a big boys guy someday
standing between Po and his daughter is
a group of dude so bad they've all got
nicknames there's bill that's William
Bedford aka Billy bedlam and Nathan
Jones aka Diamond dog and bingo Parker
our Rob arsonist don't thing
come on at least let me do John mouths
name is Cyrus Grissom aka Cyrus the
virus shut up John Cusack stop getting
Suicide Squad ideas here comes Slipknot
the man who can climb anything so return
to the 90s for a puck buster that's top
of its class because the cast is great a
it's produced by a big packed with a
Nixie and its big swing indeed you know
what I am okay ed it clearly doesn't
give an F what you're gonna do for me
now that's a report card story I Know
Why the Caged Bird Sings say anything V
con Malkovich I'm squished [ __ ]
there's all kind of diabetes type 1 type
2 please return your tray out what's
upright and locked position Mission
Impossible rogue nation Sulley
chitty-chitty-bang-bang and Emmy Award
stealer for outstanding short form
variety series Steve Buscemi the stupid
kind and generous American Hero ticking
our award planes chains and a guy from
OBO I hope he likes and no one likes an
Cyrus it's coarse rough and it gets
everywhere hey screen junkies honest
game trailers have returned on our new
channel fandom games click the box to
watch our honours take on anthem and yes
this is a new voice but don't worry
we brought backup news you
new mill views oops